a man who survived a harrowing shark
attack in Massachusetts it's speaking
out only on CBS this morning there have
been a number of recent shark sightings
on Cape Cod beaches forcing officials to
close them to tourists bill Litton was
vacationing with his family on Cape Cod
about two weeks ago
a shark bit into the 61 year olds leg
and nearly killed him CBS this morning
co-host Michelle Miller shows us his
incredible recovery Michelle good
morning good morning I was vacationing
on Cape Cod two weeks ago and remember
seeing this story good morning to
everyone
shark attacks are a rare occurrence in
Massachusetts this was the first in the
state since 2012 bill linton says he is
a lucky man to be alive and he says he
hopes others learn from his experience
your shark attack survivor yeah bill
Linton
barely escaped with his life while
swimming a few yards offshore no I'd
gone 20 minutes and that's when my leg
was seized you said it was excruciating
beyond excruciating did you see it
oh very clearly I felt like oh he's in a
wrestling match because this animal was
trying to flip me as I turn my head
around to see a big head on my leg that
belongs to the shark and this was my
advantage as it turns out his advantage
because of something he'd seen on TV you
know nature documentary 101 I know
dolphins always hit the gill that's the
place you go to attack the shark so what
did you do well that's a defensive wound
I punched it Wow and the gill
so if I hurt my hand I think I heard the
shock and it released
that's why boy just like that just like
and then what luckily there are people
within yelling distance they yelled help
and they heard me and they dragged me in
and then things really took off like all
right he's breathing he's conscious
let's stop this bleeding two nursing
grads were among the beachgoers we're
like let's get him in this towel a bunch
of people were around we all can't
started carrying him down
Linton was airlifted to a Medical Center
where he was put into a 2-day coma how
much blood did doctors say he lost all
of it
full oil change and underwent half a
dozen surgeries first walk of the day he
was discharged from the hospital good
job and sent to rehab about ten days
after the attack will you be swimming in
the ocean again yes without a single
hesitation well there might be a
hesitation there I would probably very
hesitant when I go to that very same
beach it freaked me out a little to go
in the same place even though lightning
never strikes twice right I don't know
what Bill's wife June thinks about that
she is lovely she did not want to go on
camera but she has been taking such
great care of him as well as the entire
team and she says she's grateful for all
the people who helped Bill recover
including a police officer who drove her
more than two hours to where he was
taken in Boston at the hospital it was
just a harrowing Drive for her so she
was really happy that someone came along
to help so go for the eyes or the gills
or the snout the snout yes there we go
or just stay on the beach truer words
have never been spoken Michelle what a
great thank you so much